took me 15 years to build my NBA career
it took me 7 Seconds to lose it it's not
lack of time that we suffer from it's
lack of Direction and commitment in Our
Lives who you spend time with is who you
become it's time to focus you'll defeat
the person you were yesterday the person
you need to compete with the most is the
old you identity is who are you beyond
the problem you got to lock in once you
get to your spot you you got to get
focused once you get to your spot you
got to get stable once you get to your
spot you can't move it do not give up
walk on the court again run on the field
again step into the arena again try it
one more time and after you do that
you're going to come back for more you
cannot be a champion